trois attaques peut-être cette nous
dit-on de source policière en tout cas
au moins trois ont été perpétrés à paris
et autour de paris
on n'a jamais connu un attentat comme ça
dans les rues de paris on n'a jamais été
confronté à une action ans de guerre
[Musique]
c'est la guerre avec l'odeur de la
poudre du sang la vision c'est la guerre
on pense pas trop hein soit on l'a on
essaie surtout de prendre les bonnes
décisions
déterminées qui a fait quoi
très bon
avec qui et pourquoi
c'est une toile le coin s'est passé
tellement énorme je pars de trois
personnes qui nous ont tiré dessus un an
après on me parle d'une quantité de gens
on me parle du financement des armes de
tout devient énorme
45000 code 45 mille pièces de procédure
mille sept cent quarante parties civiles
et 350 avocat ce jour au moins six mois
d'audiences dans une salle de 600 places
spécialement construite au coeur du
palais de justice de paris
c'est un procédé très grande ampleur et
qui donc n'est comparable à rien ce
procès en appel choix il doit être
historique
que n'at-on pas fait que n'at-on pas
empêché comment ces attentats ont ils pu
se produire
c'est la liberté qui aura le dernier mot
vous avez agi de manière effroyable vous
allez être condamné de manière
démocratique
[Musique]
on
non
on me téléphone la première fois le 22
mars je pense que tout sincèrement que
c'est pour me dire voilà on les a
trouvés ils y attend un échange de tirs
comme on a eu à l'arrêt du drissa forêt
est malheureusement non c'est ce sont
ces pour une explosion à l'aéroport
[Musique]
assez rapidement je me rends à la police
fédérale et puis au centre de crise et
je suis à peine arrivé au centre de
crise que nous avons les premières
images de l'autre la deuxième explosion
une heure plus tard dans le métro
malbec dans le quartier européen
rien
une
explosion dans la station métro malbec
il y a des victimes il ya des blessés il
ya des personnes décédées
[Musique]
au matin du 22 on apprend effectivement
les attentats dans le métro et à
l'aéroport de zaventem moi je me
souviens j'ai tout de suite téléphoné à
mon homologue pour donc à frédéric vend
mieux pour le lui dire effectivement
toute l'émotion qu'on ressente et puis
lui manifester effectivement tout
l'amitié le soutien dans l'ailé des
responsabilités qu'ils allaient être les
siennes
[Musique]
on a
m
[Musique]
on sait maintenant et il est clair à ce
moment là que cette cellule 22 mars 13
novembre n'en feront plus qu'une et que
l'ensemble de la trentaine de personnes
qui a participé à l'organisation et ses
deux attentats avaient été la même et
que c'était la même structure avec le
même mode opératoire les mêmes
commanditaires et les mêmes procédés le
fait qu'ils aient eu des victimes en
france le fait qu'il y ait des victimes
en belgique nous prive à tout jamais de
la notion de réussite puisqu'on ne les a
pas eues avant qu'il ne passe à l'acte
il est l'un des deux kamikazes de
l'aéroport de bruxelles najim lâchera
oui ici à gauche de l'image
c'était l'artificier des attentats de
paris le belge de 24 ans a été identifié
par son adn les deux autres kamikazes de
bruxelles eux aussi sont liées aux
attentats de paris
deux frères khalid ait ibrahim el
batraoui leur empreinte au permis de les
identifier formellement très rapidement
on se rend compte de qui c'est donc
parce que ben voilà on sait que ce
groupe là est dans la nature nous avons
cette fameuse image à l'aéroport avec le
mot chapeau
[Musique]
ce qu'on voit sur les images est ce que
les belges et toute l'europe découvre
sur les images des attentats c'est qu'il
ya un homme qui sera pas explosé qui
s'enlacent qu'on appelle le mot chapeau
et au bout de quelques jours les
enquêteurs européens n'ont pas de doute
l'homme au chapeau c'est également celui
qu'on l'a vu descendre à paris dans la
voiture de salades des sommes c'est
mohamed abri
[Musique]
ce même homme qui a fui au dernier
moment les attentats du 13 au moment de
commettre l'attentât du 22 mars à
zaventem se sauve également
à la requête du parquet fédéral et du
juge d'instruction en plus elle la
police ni demande de diffuser la vie
suivre une fois les bombes explosaient à
7h58 l'homme à la veste claire et au
chapeau est sorti du bâtiment il est
passé devant le sheraton et à tourner à
droite pour emprunter le parking avis et
se retire du site de l'aéroport
il a poursuivi sa route sur la chaussée
de louvain où il est filmé à 9h49
puis l'a emprunté l'avenue de la
brabançonne où il disparaîtra au
carrefour de la rue du noyer
[Musique]
ah bon
quand sont diffusés je crois les photos
des terroristes il ya un chauffeur de
taxi qui se présente à la police en
disant attendez moi j'ai conduit des
hommes
là à l'aéroport le chauffeur de taxi qui
dépose appris ni et les frères bac raoui
à l'aéroport de bruxelles fait
immédiatement le lien et les perspicace
il fait le lien entre les trois gars qui
la dépose et qu'il a été chercher rue
max os avec les trois valises qui avait
l'air assez nerveux qui a priori voulait
absolument mettre la quatrième valise
dans la voiture et que ça n'allait pas
et qui était un peu déçu que la
quatrième valise nadal elle pendant donc
lui a fait le lien et il a directement
été trouvé un poste de police pour
raconter son histoire de là
qu'ils ont pu ré reconstitué en fait le
trajet est assez rapidement revenir sur
la rue et l'appartement la rue max rose
[Musique]
nous on nous demande d'aller de nouveau
dans la précipitation
non préparés à les faire une en une
perquisition renforcer rue max rose on
arrive sur plage arrivé en premier sur
place en moto en fait avec deux snipers
la colonne est en cours dans les
embouteillages et là on nous dit voilà
c'est au 8e étage s'il me semble bien ce
huitième étage
[Musique]
la colonne d'assaut arif est assez
rapidement on nous dit qu'il faut
absolument rentrer pour avoir des
éléments et pourront poids s'il ya plus
personne dans cet appartement ils font
leurs fouilles y a personne il trouve
une valise une perquisition a été
effectuée à cette adresse et a permis de
découvrir quinze kilos d'explosifs de
type t'es atp 150 litres d'acétone 30
litres d'eau oxygénée des détonateurs
une valise remplie de clous et de vis
ainsi que du matériel destinés à
confectionner des engins explosifs dans
une poubelle de la même rue les
enquêteurs ont trouvé un ordinateur
contenant le testament de ibrahim el
batraoui et un policier vigilant maître
chien va retrouver dans une poubelle
quelques dizaines de mètres plus loin un
ordinateur qui est mis à la va vite dans
une poubelle publique
[Musique]
on
quand ils arrivent ils voient dans la
rue le camion poubelle qu'elle est
arrivé donc à quelques minutes près
l'ordinateur aurait été perdue à jamais
les enquêteurs ont trouvé un ordinateur
dans une poubelle cet ordinateur avait
été abandonné par les auteurs des
attentats de bruxelles qui a été
évidemment exploiter et qui a permis
d'avoir des qu'une connaissance des
attentats de paris parce que certains
éléments concernés également les
attentats de paris
cet ordinateur de la rue max roche va
après que les spécialistes et puis
retrouver certains dossiers
avoir plusieurs fichiers qu'ils vont
nous intéresser d'abord ils vont avoir
un dossier qui s'appelle dossier 13
novembre la date doit faire écho auprès
d'élus des enquêteurs dans lequel ils
vont retrouver différents dossiers qui
pose un peu question
[Musique]
il ya un dossier qui va s'appeler groupe
omar on sait que le nom de guerre là
cunha de abdelhamid abou oud il ya des
homards dedans on pense que c'est un
groupe dans lequel yade abdelamid abou
oud et chakib akrou confirmé avec
quelqu'un en outre il y avait un dossier
groupe français le groupe français sont
des trois attaquants du bataclan et sans
doute mis là la fille même s'il était
beige il avait passé beaucoup de temps
avec eux il est revenue avec eux en
voiture il ya un dossier qui s'appelle
groupes irakiens on va penser aux deux
terroristes qui sont mort au stade de
france qui était d'origine irakienne
dans le maintien de section il ya un
dossier de groupes skipper
qui s'est passé le soir du 13 novembre
également bart de bruxelles de leur
appartement conspiratif deux hommes qui
sont mandatés par abba houde pour aller
faire alors cénac leur version pour
aller faire du repérage sur les reports
de ski pole mais on pense plutôt qu'il
devait faire sauter dans la foule de
l'aéroport un des plus grand aéroport
d'europe et il ya un dossier qui
s'appelle groupe metro alors là c'est
l'interrogation est ce qu'il s'agissait
d'un attentat prévu au métro de
bruxelles ou paris peut-être le 18e
c'était peut-être un attentat dans le
métro là on a beaucoup d'interrogations
n'a pas de réponse en fait on n'arrive
pas à faire entrer complètement les
différents groupes sur les différents
sites dont on commence à avoir une bonne
idée on trouve la trace des projets
d'attentats de l'attentât du 13 novembre
l'attentât de belgique et des futurs
attentats la défense
un micro et il est évoqué aussi
une fan zone
[Musique]
et la référence à des frères en france
dont on ne connait pas les identités
mais qui serait en capacité de fournir
des armes pour ceux qui seraient
capables de passer à l'acte
[Musique]
nous savions qu'il y avait un personnage
très dangereux qui était en train de
préparer des attentats de masse et que
ce personnage était vraisemblablement
situé dans une ville de la région
parisienne
quelques heures après l'interpellation
de reda cricket à boulogne billancourt
son domicile est perquisitionné à
argenteuil la perquisition permet de
découvrir selon les mots du procureur de
paris un arsenal d'armes et d'explosifs
d'une ampleur inédite l'homme de 34 ans
était selon le ministère de l'intérieur
à un stade avancé de préparation d'un
attentat en france en mars 2016
à la dgsi va interpeller
reda cricket qui était apparu dans une
filière jihadiste belge avec about
cricket avait une planque dans lequel va
être retrouvé un arsenal absolument
stupéfiant et un magistrat m'avait
confié qu' il y avait encore plus
d'armes que pour les attentats du 13
novembre la réalité de ce dossier c'est
qu'on a une cache d'armes la question
c'est de savoir si c'est leur ai dit
qu'à des armes du 13 novembre
planes où je suis effectivement de cette
procédure d'aidé des noms de
commanditaires qui sont en effectivement
présents dans les procédures y perd
cacher guînes juifs thalys sans pour
autant que dans cette procédure ce soit
aussi facilement établi
ça témoignait de la même logique au
niveau du modus operandi au haut niveau
de la l'ambition poursuivie au niveau
aussi des analyses de contact entre
personnes on était quand même dans la
même mouvance
[Musique]
après salle abdeslam c'était l'homme qui
était le plus recherché suite aux
attentats de paris mohamed abri ni a été
interpellé anderlecht les enquêteurs se
demander à juste titre s'il avait ou non
participer à ces attentats serait-il
d'ailleurs le mot chapeau en fuite
depuis les explosions de l'aéroport de
zaventem
hommen a prédit c'est particulier parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui est assez
qui était passée assez inaperçue même si
on l'a vu du début
[Musique]
on le voit sur les vidéos qui sont
prises dans les stations-service et en
région parisienne il accompagne abdeslam
pour organiser les locations et donc il
fait il fait un aller retour
il aurait dû être où il aurait pu être
dans l'attentât du 13 et devait être
dans l'attentât de zaventem et y laisse
son complice sur place et lui
s'enfuit
savoir cabrini c'est quand même un
protagoniste assez important dans toute
l'histoire parce que c'est on parle
toujours de salades l'islam mais a pris
ni
nous paraît beaucoup plus intelligente
est beaucoup plus manipulateur dans
toute cette histoire
il ya un épisode qui est très révélateur
de l'ambition de l'état islamique sur
cet attentat du 13 novembre c'est que
moi mais d'abris va faire un court
séjour en syrie
il voit about et repart directement en
angleterre où il va aller à manchester
visiter le stade de foot de manchester
leur soi disant c'est parce qu'il était
fan de foot
certains éléments laissent à penser
qu'il était en train de faire des
repérages en tout cas c'est comme ça que
l'on analysé les services de
renseignement britanniques le 8 avril
m'hamed a brignais est arrêté sans doute
dénoncé par la personne auprès de qui
cherchait à trouver du soutien il est
arrêté en der leck et un autre membre du
réseau osamac ryan qui lui devait se
faire exploser dans le métro ce faire a
été également à bruxelles le même jour
le 8 avril donc le 8 avril en vingt
quatre personnes sous sous les verrous
membre de la cellule
on
peut penser qu'à ce moment là le gros de
ce réseau qui a commis donc les
attentats bataclan terrasse stade de
france et bruxelles qui était déjà le
réseau de verviers que nous pensons que
ce réseau a été en grande partie
détruits qu'elle ne veut pas dire que le
terrorisme islamiste a terminé hélas sa
sale besogne puisque ils sont toujours
en train de finaliser un certain nombre
d'individus et de nouveau visé il faut
bien comprendre ce qu'était le contexte
cette période est un contexte de menaces
très élevées avec des risques
d'attentats
en réplique et des organisations de de
l'état islamique en irak et en syrie qui
était qui monte en puissance
sommes face à l'organisation de l'euro
une compétition
sportive considérable avec énormément de
deux lieux
sont reconcentrés des publics nombreux
les fans zones sont toute cette période
là et qu'une période de lumière de la
terre est vraiment sous une pression
incroyable faute d'avoir un réseau aussi
dense aussi capable de mener des
opérations d'envergure ils vont utiliser
des individus avec peu de moyens pour
commettre des actes effroyables
[Musique]
commandant de police du commissariat
proche hors service a été tué à coups de
couteau
l'assaillant dont nous ne connaissons
pas l'identité s'est réfugié dans la
maison de ce commandant
en y entrant les forces de l'ordre qui
agissaient avec une autorisation en
légitime défense d'autrui ont trouvé le
corps d'une femme
il s'agit très probablement de la
campagne du commandant qui est elle-même
fonctionnaires au commissariat et un
enfant de 3 ans choquée mais indemne
nous interrompons vos programmes pour
une prise d'antenne spéciale ce soir
vers 22h40 un camion a foncé dans la
foule sur la promenade des anglais à
nice alors que les gens assistaient au
feu d'artifice du 14 juillet le
pare-brise criblé de balles les pneus
crevés le poids lourd termine sa course
au bout de la promenade des anglais
après deux kilomètres d'un parcours
meurtrier
[Musique]
attentat cette fois dans l'église de
saint-etienne du rouvray près de rouen
seine-maritime église que deux hommes
armés de couteaux ont investi ce matin
en plein office le prêtre qui officiait
un homme d'église de 86 ans était tué à
l'heure où l'on parle un autre otage se
trouve entre la vie et la mort les trois
autres ont pu prendre la fuite
[Musique]
quel souvenir d'une année noire on
vivait sous la menace et la pression
constante des attentats qui se
multiplier
on était débordé de travail
j'ai souvenir en particulier d'être
revenue de vacances
en début de 2016 en trouvant mes
collègues qui avait été de permanence au
mois de juillet totalement exsangues
après les attentats qui s'étaient
multipliées à cette époque à chaque fois
qu'un attentat ce qu est ce qu mais je
suis certain que les douze juges de
cette galerie se demande si l'auteur a
déjà était entendu par l'un d'entre eux
c'est
intimement l'idée qu'on qu'on a raté
quelque chose et on est on vit je crois
tous cette cette responsabilité
[Musique]
vous le profil des avocats qui entrent
dans nos procédures est assez varié
puisqu'il ya quand même de nombreux
avocats qui sont choisis pour ceux qui
ne choisissent pas d'avocat l'ordre a
prévu un système de désignation qui
prévilégie la désignation d'avocats de
la conférence donc en principe les
meilleurs avocats de la jeune génération
troisième sujet la nuit nous appartient
à terre pour l'affirmative madame léa
d'ordi
[Musique]
la conférence des avocats du barreau de
paris c'est un concours d'éloquence
assez prestigieux c'est une institution
qui date de plus de 200 ans et qui
permet en fait chaque année d'élire une
promotion de 12 jeunes avocats on sait
que si on fait partie des douze élus à
l'issue de ce concours on aura pendant
un an le monopole de la défense pénale
dans les dossiers criminels et dans les
dossiers de terroristes dans lesquelles
les mises en cause n'ont pas d'avocat
choisi donc on sera commis d'office est
désigné pour les assister pour toute la
durée de la procédure lorsque tout
commencera sur la nuit ça à vous et moi
et jusqu'au dernier cri
[Applaudissements]
le troisième tour se déroule au mois de
novembre 2015 il faut savoir qu'on tire
au sort des sujets qui nous sont opposés
et au moment où nous les découvrons et
bien c'est le jour justement des
attentats au bataclan et au stade saint
denis ce qu'on sait en passant ce
troisième tour ce jour-là que si on
était lui à l'issue nous allons faire
partie des avocats qui vont être
désignés pour assister potentiellement
les auteurs de ces actes
dans le courant de l'année 2016 la
galerie entité rom appelle pour me dire
qu'un dossier j'arrive à la galerie et
là je vois
une dizaine d'hommes cagoulés avec un
mise en cause au milieu qui a un masque
sur les yeux un casque sur les oreilles
[Musique]
je me dis qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel et je comprends par la suite il
s'agit du dos et du 13 novembre et on va
se retrouver donc dans un box pour avoir
un entretien confidentiel entre l'avocat
et le client et à notre demande le gign
va donc des entraves et les mises en
cause et les installer avec nous dans le
box leur enlever le masque les écouteurs
pour puissent se discuter
le premier sentiment que j'ai eu
peut-être la peur de pas être à la
hauteur
il ya deux personnes aussi qu'ils vont
être présents dans le box qui ont été
arrêtés en autriche parce qu'en fait ils
revenaient par la route des migrants
leur faux papiers n'étaient pas assez
bien fait on les arrête dans un en
autriche juste après les attentats
on pense très fortement khider pas
retenir également à la cndh du 13
[Musique]
donc la personne pour laquelle
j'interviens ce jour là se nomme adèle
haddadi c'est un homme qui a aujourd'hui
33 ans qui a vécu une vie somme toute
assez banal en algérie et qui en 2015 a
pris le chemin de la scierie avant
d'être choisie pour partir avec le
commando du stade 5 me mon client est
pakistanais il a fait un long parcours
pour arriver notamment en zones irako
syrienne où il est resté un certain
temps et ensuite il est remonté en
direction de la france monsieur haddad y
va être incarcéré lui à la maison
d'arrêt de lyon je suis son seul lien
avec l'extérieur en réalité donc il est
quand même extrêmement important que je
rendais visite aussi régulière que
possible pour préparer ces
interrogatoires qui vont être régulier
puisque tous les quatre à six mois il va
voir le magistrat instructeur pour
avancer dans le cas de l'instruction
répondre à des questions
le juge d'instruction le monopole de
l'interrogatoire des personnes mises en
examen et ça ça représente une part très
importante de notre travail on passe des
journées entières avec les mises en
examen à plusieurs reprises on les
interroge 5 6 7 fois un interrogatoire
mais c'est valable dans d'autres
matières comme dans toutes les autres
n'est pas une discussion de salon en
réalité mon échange sur des charges il
est le moyen de donner à la personne
mise en examen
les éléments officiellement les éléments
qui se trouve dans le dossier lui dire
voilà monsieur contre vous il ya ça ça
et ça ou contre vous il y a tel élément
on n'a pas pu prouver que là vous étiez
là à ce moment là
[Musique]
les premiers interrogatoires on essaye
souvent
d'obtenir le maximum de renseignements
de la part d'une mise en examen donc les
questions sont courtes les réponses sont
longues du moins on l'espère c'est à
dire que généralement
le premier interrogatoire
vient disons faire le point sur un
parcours sur les sources d'un engagement
idéologique ou religieux
[Musique]
vous
ça va être des interrogatoires fleuve
effectivement on va d'abord l'interrogé
sur sa vie son parcours sa part sculpté
son voyage des choses assez personnel ça
peut prendre une journée entière de fer
en fait le résumé de la vie d'un homme
et puis y aura ensuite un interrogatoire
plus spécifique une fois qu'on aura un
peu avant son instruction pour le
confronter à des éléments objectifs de
téléphonie à de surveillance
d'interrogatoire d'autres accusés mise
en examen
[Musique]
va entrer au gré des commissions
rogatoires qui vous montrer des
exploitations de supports numériques
dans le dur si je veux dire avec des
questions beaucoup plus technique sur le
contenu
des applications qu'ils ont pu
fréquenter les contacts qu'ils ont pu
avoir les uns et les autres avec par
exemple à devenir accro syrienne qui
font que la question est souvent plus
longue que la réponse
on
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
il faut jamais oublier que quels que
soient les faits qui ont été commises
les personnes qui comparaissent devant
vous sont des personnes qui sont
présumées innocentes et ce sont des
êtres humains donc voilà et ils doivent
être traités de cette manière là alors
moi je n'arrache pas les aveux des
personnes me dit ce qu'elle soit neutre
ne me dira ceci dit je me permets de
l'est de lait confrontés à certaines
contradictions c'est sûr que si la
personne nous raconte de a à z tout ce
qui s'est passé ça nous fait gagner
beaucoup de temps donc c'est plutôt ça
qu'on recherche c'est à dire pas à faire
avoué
absolument la personne mais à la faire
parler à elle faire en sorte qu'elle
qu'elle nous raconte ce qui s'est passé
que ça la met en cause où ça la met hors
de cause d'ailleurs
[Musique]
tous ces attentes à paris certaines
personnes ne sont admis par de leur
responsabilité dans mon cabinet
d'autres - former des éléments que nous
ignorions donc une audition le but du no
10 oc quand même faire avancer un
dossier sont des magistrats aussi qui
vont être à mille qui vont être adroit
et qui vont les amener assez facilement
à s'expliquer en l'occurrence avec allah
dit ça va se passer plutôt bien pendant
l'instruction puisque c'est quelqu'un
qui va vouloir donner des explications
assez fourni au magistrat instructeur et
être le plus précis possible je crois
dans ces auditions qui seront très
longues de ce fait il c'est important
d'essayer de comprendre parce que cette
compréhension devraient être transmises
aux six autres à la cour d'assises qui
et c'est un début de réponse pour les
libertés civiles elle aussi elle veut
comprendre le pourquoi pourquoi on en
est arrivé là
à paris les victimes des attentats du 13
novembre et leurs proches ont commencé à
être reçu à huis clos par les juges
d'instruction chargés de l'enquêté
quelques mille personnes ont été
conviées l'objectif de ces réunions
prévues pour durer trois jours et de
permettre au juge d'exposer les avancées
de l'enquêté en france et en belgique
aussi juge d'instruction qui les
reçoivent rescapé des familles de
victimes ont beaucoup de questions à
poser
vous voulez que les parties civiles
sache ce qui était réellement le dossier
ce qu'étaient nos investigations et à
quoi correspondait nos investigations ce
pour quoi on était missionné ça a été la
première réunion nous étions plus dans
le dans le dans le comment dire ça dans
le descriptif de l'événement du 13
devant et c'est ce qui nous touchait le
plus on avait besoin on a des beaucoup
de questions je me rend compte assez
rapidement que ces tentaculaire que
c'est
que le jus de fessiers connaît très bien
le dossier mais que c'est énorme couac
il ya les enquêtes partout il ya il ya
des noms partout je vais en vente il
faut si je veux comprendre que je prenne
suffisamment de recul pour comprendre la
globalité
l'enquêté progressait très vite très
bien d'une certaine manière nous étions
contents de pouvoir annoncer cela aux
parties civiles et
nous nous avons
tout de suite compris que ce qu'on
pouvait leur apporter ne leur suffisait
pas du tout aujourd'hui ce qu'on attend
c'est de savoir quelles sont les
responsabilités
pourquoi ma soeur est morte on quand
elle a été transportée con côté de la
rive à l'autre est ce qu'elle est morte
à ce moment-là ce qu'elle est morte au
début on ne sait pas où on sent autour
de nous tous ces gens qui ont besoin de
parler de leur douleur de leur cas
personnel de leur mort et c'est encore
de pense qu'après c'est encore très
compliqué avec les je pense que le
contact avec les victimes et et est très
compliqué encore la première année et
cette première réunion a été un
véritable choc pour moi on a été
confronté au mas chagrin au traumatisme
énorme qui avait subi ses victimes je me
souviens de deux questions qui ne
portait pas du tout sur les progrès où
les perspectives de l'enquète mais
davantage sur des points sur lesquels
nous étions incapables de répondre comme
pourquoi sentinelle n'étaient pas
intervenues pourquoi mon mari ou monfils
t'il passé deux heures sur une civière
et c'est ça il eu des questions par
entité quand même très difficile
tu t'es peut-être parfois injuste mais
c'était la première fois qu'ils ont un
représentant de l'état en face d'eux
j'ai senti que lors des réunions
suivantes le décalage ça me laissait
progressivement le temps passant
les blessures du passé était sans doute
un peu moins vive et le climat était
plus apaisé
le magistrat est également revenu
longuement sur le silence du seul membre
des commandos toujours en vie
le nantais 130 victimes a été étrennée
par le ch à sa salade cela
aucune réaction
c'est l'inquiétude des associations et
des victimes des attentats du 13
novembre à paris le seul membre du
commando survivants salle abdeslam
continue à se murer dans le silence à
tel point que ses avocats ont renoncé ce
matin à le défendre la justice elle est
là simplement pour comprendre ce qui
s'est passé et on peut pas comprendre
s'il se tait s'il dit rien on lui
demandait pas de collaborer de manière
claire nette et précise mais simplement
de lui dire ce que lui avait fait ce que
les autres peut-être avait pu faire et
de donner un certain nombre de réponses
aux questions qui étaient posées par les
magistrats
[Musique]
si quelqu'un décide de se taire c'est
pas un échec du magistrat parce que
c'est un moyen de défense qui est
d'ailleurs prévue dans le code de
procédure pénale si le silence est en
droit il peut pas être un frein à la
hausse investigations donc
très bien monsieur vous vous taisez mais
très bien mon droit aussi c'est de vous
poser toutes les questions que j'ai
envie et qui disent rien c'est leur
droit le droit au silence est un droit
reconnu il me dit seraient ils ne disent
rien la cour d'assises en tête dure à ce
qu'elle soit en déduire
[Musique]
quand vous avez un atteint 2 c'est comme
les attentats de paris et vous avez
plusieurs stratégiques ce qui vous
souhaitez voir embarras devant la cour
d'assises
soient tous souhaité voir comparaître
les personnes qui ont été sur les
terrasses en pierre et ça fera quelques
personnes soit vous souhaitez voir
comparaître également certaines
personnes qui jouent un rôle logistique
qui étaient présents qui ont été
construits une aide
est-ce que vous souhaitez également voir
comparaître les personnes comprenant les
fameux faux documents en ce qui me
concerne la réponse est oui qui donc
forcément l'enquète prend plus de temps
et est à et à différents volets et avec
les autres mes collègues français nous
étions d'accord sur cette vision
[Musique]
ces opérations sont directement
commandés depuis jaca puisque il y à ces
enregistrements qui était après cryptée
et est envoyé qui était un peu le
système de communication de l'état
islamique
il s'adresse à quelqu'un a la baraka que
le dossier avec beaucoup de
voilà de
probabilités identifie effectivement
comme étant oussama atar
[Musique]
les services vont prendre un certain
temps identifier parce qu'il est sous
cunha donc il a un nom qui n'est pas
aussi douce amara tard
[Musique]
quand il ya une mutation du groupe parce
qu'on a après un attentat parce qu'on a
un qui se fait arrêter ils reprennent
toujours leurs ordres auprès nous
samatar qui reste clairement le
commanditaire et le coordinateur de
l'ensemble de la cellule jusqu'au bout
c'est un belge francophone qui a très
rapidement me grimper les échelons de
l'état islamique a acquis 2 les
responsabilités très importante au sein
de dia tu as a matter c'est un ancien
aussi du jihâd et il est d'abord arrêté
par les américains lors de
l'intervention en irak y passe par la
prison d'abou ghraïb au moment où se
retrouvaient d'autres personnes qui a
été un peu le départ de l'état islamique
en fait
est un certain moment il est libéré dabo
gré et puis rentrer en belgique il reste
moins d'un an en belgique et puis
retourne là-bas en syrie au moment la
situation se dégrade en syrie donc c'est
que c'est quelqu'un que l'on connaît
ce qui est intéressant les consommateurs
c'est qu'il est le cousin des frères
batraoui qui vont mourir lors des
attentats du 22 mars qui sont des
logisticiens de l'ensemble de
l'opération qui vont louer des
appartements qui vont la coordination il
ya le frère de oussama atar yacine à
tarte blanquette et le procès devront
démontrer son degré d'application
donc il ya des liens parfois très forts
de fratrie ou de cousinage entre les
différents membres du groupe
parmi les commanditaires on va retrouver
en l'organisation de la miata cette
organisation d'intelligence et
d'espionnage au sein de l'état islamique
et plus spécifiquement de ces opérations
extérieures le chef de la minuad à
bouloc man lui a certainement donné son
blanc-seing à oussama atar sur
l'organisation comme mohamed adnani
porte parole de l'état islamique et qui
supervisait les opérations de la miata
même si il n'est pas renvoyé devant la
cour d'assises
le franco-tunisien boubakeur al-hakim on
sait qu'il était l'adjoint d'oussama
tard et c'était celui qui drivait tous
les projets d'attentats sur la zone
europe je pense personnellement que des
hommes comme abdel nasser ben youssef ou
samir noirs étaient au courant c'est une
toile de quoi c'est sympa c'est
tellement énorme on entend des noms on
n'arrive même plus à se repérer opiacés
en fait on se rend compte tenu de la
complexité
ça nous tombe encore dessus en fait
[Musique]
qui nous fait la guerre pas des
individus une organisation une
organisons qui s'est érigé en état il
faut donc répondre pas simplement en
neutralisant les terroristes qui sont
ici ou pas loin il faut répondre y
compris en frappant la tête de cette
organisation
mon
oh
[Musique]
tous ces hommes là vont être éliminés
entre 2016 et fin 2010 est
essentiellement par des frappes de
drones américains
ils n'ont pas été éliminés
dans un désir de vengeance suite au aux
attentats du 13 novembre ils ont été
éliminés dans un souci pragmatique qui
était d'entraver la cellule des opex qui
nous tuer tant de gens en europe et
d'éviter qu'elle de nouveaux attentats
soient perpétrés moi je suis contre la
peine de mort
après quelle est l'alternative pour un
pays comme la france
ben je suis bien content de pas être
décisionnaire à ce moment là
[Musique]
j'avais l'habitude de commencer chaque
fois les réunions de partie civile en
leur disant le temps
judiciaire n'est jamais le même que le
temps
de l'aveu des victimes et vous serez
toujours déçu parce que vous ne
comprendrez pas pourquoi on met autant
de temps l'enjeu que l'on avait tous les
6 c'était d'essayer de mener cette
enquête le plus rapidement possible et
on avait espéré la clôture et en trois
ans
on n'est pas arrivé
[Musique]
après quatre ans d'enquêté les juges
d'instruction ont terminé leurs
investigations sur les attentats du 13
novembre 2015 et le dossier le plus
abouti de toute la vague d'attentats
islamistes en france et donc le plus
volumineux 45000 cote 45 mille pièces de
procédure mille sept cent quarante
parties civiles et 350 avocat ce jour
[Musique]
tu peux vous dire que les quatre ans ou
ont paru très court surtout quand j'ai
dû reprendre le dossier c'est très court
parce que les investigations sont
tellement nombreuses qu'en réalité on
fait quelquefois des rapprochements très
important entre une information venue de
suède une venue de belgique une venue de
france c'est quelque fois au bout de
trois ans d'instruction qu'on le
découvre sa relance des instructions et
on sait qu'on a une deadline absolue qui
est quatre ans c'est à dire la durée de
la détention provisoire du premier mise
en examen du dossier
[Musique]
finalement une enquête longue déjà c'est
rassurant candy qui travaille longtemps
et et ça nous laisse le temps aussi à
nous de nous relever un petit peu cette
enquête 1 c'est un dur et pendant 1587
jour je sais compter
c'était
personne n'a jamais vu en france un
dossier de cette ampleur nous en sommes
sûrs n'additionne l'enquète française et
l'enquète belge 104 déjà rejoint le
dossier français nous en sommes à
quelque chose qui doit représenter un
million de pages c'est impensable ça a
été fait par
la belgique la france europol eurojust
les autorités hollandaises aussi
travaillé avec nous ne l'oublions pas en
équipe comme une enquête et après une
quantité importante de pays européens
ont apporté leur aide par de 0,1 une
part de d'appels qui sont passés depuis
le bataclan la police
et on arrive sinon plus tard avec les
noms leurs déplacements les lieux les
cachent les armes les identités c'est à
la fois que
glaçant
et c'est un
c'est un véritable polar
[Musique]
pour moi il reste plusieurs points
obscurs que les juges d'instruction ont
bien noté les armes d'où venaient les
armes ils ont une intuition mais ils
n'ont pas pu le prouver il ya le
déplacement de salles abdeslam pourquoi
il abandonne sa voiture pourquoi ils
seront à châtillon pourquoi il abandonne
sa ceinture explosive
il ya la composition des équipes aussi
le fait que mohamed al rimi équité au
dernier moment les logements conspiratif
il ya un dernier point qui est très
clairement floués on sait pas du tout le
soir des attentats la voiture que
pilotait salade et sam dans laquelle il
y avait les terroristes qui vont se
faire sauter au stade de france se rend
à l'aéroport charles de gaulle en en
début de soirée mais on apprend des
attentats en 30 minutes et ce qu'ils ont
déposés quelqu'un qui sera reparti parce
qu'on est sensé
[Musique]
on a enquêté en france en belgique mais
aussi dans le monde entier et devant la
quantité
d'informations qui nous est donnée est
difficile de faire la fine bouche et de
dire non vous avez passé bossé ils sont
beaucoup ce travail d'instruction de 4
ans
fixe les termes du débat il
si vous voulez circonscrit d'une
certaine manière tout ce qui va se dire
et se plaider au cours du procès à venir
[Musique]
le procès à venir est un procès
qu'on ne peut pas imaginer et à partir
de là il me semblait qu'il fallait
alerter pour éviter d'avoir la tentation
de comparer avec des dossiers précédents
et de dire on a déjà fait ça avec
d'autres dossiers non on n'a jamais fait
ça pour l'instant
il y avait à la fois la dimension de la
quantité quantité de partie civile quand
tu étais d'avocats quantité de
journalistes
il y avait un aspect purement budgétaire
de dire attention c'est un procès qui va
coûter très cher à la justice et il faut
aussi budgétés
les problèmes sécuritaires aussi été
sont évidemment à prendre en
considération
et puis il y avait aussi la longueur 1
du procès puisque moi j'ai compté
fillier ce procès ainsi à une durée de
six mois
[Musique]
nous avons donné tout ce que nous avons
pu notre énergie notre compétence notre
opiniâtreté pour conduire ce dossier
du jour où nous en avons hérité au jour
où nous l'avons pourriture et
c'est précisément la cour d'assises qui
dira si oui ou non et les débats le
diront si oui ou non il était exemplaire
on verra bien
[Musique]